that's a really huge milestone for
SpaceX and certainly for the space
industry no one has ever soft landed a
liquid rocket boost stage before and I
think this bodes very well for achieving
reusability as people have maybe heard
me say
like what what SpaceX has done this bar
is evolutionary but they're not
revolutionary and I think if we can make
if we can recover the stage intact and
relaunch it the potential is there for a
truly revolutionary impact in space
transport transport costs with with each
successive launch we have several more
launches this year we expect to get more
and more precise with the landing and if
all goes well I am optimistic that we'll
be able to land the stage back at Cape
Canaveral by the end of the year so
that's all great stuff and I think
assuming that happens what we should be
able to refi the the main boo stage
sometime next year there's this sort of
a huge day because we've been trying to
do this
SpaceX for a long time and it's been 12
years and we sort of finally did it and
now we just got a break point back home
in one piece